hey it's evan i believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and listen
guys you need to pay attention to the
details in your business I get these
emails from from readers and from people
who are trying to promote their business
and it drives me nuts how they don't pay
attention to what they're sending me
okay it's so easy to send out emails
cost you nothing but the people who are
receiving them takes their time to read
it and this stuff really pisses me off
so this is one that came in from Amy who
I've no idea who she is it's spam
basically hello blank my name is Amy I'm
a regularly regular reader of your blog
insert name of blog or website named
after following the content provided on
your site I really really like to read
more about insert blog topic I also
think the other viewers would also enjoy
this is crazy like she's just using a
template letter not even doing a mail
merge properly and is wasting my time
now I don't even know what website she's
from because I'd love to call them out
and say what a bad job they're doing but
she didn't share that this is not the
way to market your business okay having
somebody spam bloggers and influencers
is not the way to build a successful
company if you want to reach out to
people like me your other influences in
your community you have to make sure
that you are actually paying attention
reach out to them personally don't have
your assistant do it and and do a
terrible job and not actually care right
we can see and you can see two
entrepreneurs have a big BS meter ok we
know when something is genuine and we
know something when something is fake
you know what I'm talking about so don't
be fake in your marketing don't be fake
pay attention to the details and really
care if you want to reach out to me i'm
a pretty accessible guy okay i think i'm
more accessible than a lot of people i
have my email address available I answer
questions on YouTube you want to reach
out to me it's not that hard but put a
little bit of effort in at least okay
this is ridiculous I don't like wasting
my time I love helping entrepreneurs I
know it's hard I know running the
business is is terrifying and scary and
takes up a lot of investment and and
we're all trying to do things that are
way above what we're used to doing so I
want to help
like I really love helping you guys out
I love helping entrepreneurs and I spend
my time doing it but when I get stuff
like this it bothers me because this is
taken away my time for me to help other
entrepreneurs who actually are hungry
and who need help and can go on and do
something great okay so think about what
you're doing pay attention to your
market and pay attention to the details
and only put something out there if it's
genuine otherwise you're going to be
wasting your time or your assistants
time and your money going down the wrong
path okay and you're going to upset the
influencers instead of doing what you
want them to do which is be nice to you
and talk about your product that's my
little rent for the day you got me all
upset Amy which probably isn't your real
name anyway anyway thank you guys I feel
like I've unloaded a little bit today so
I feel a little bit better so thank you
for listening for those of you listening
if you liked it please give it a thumbs
up below and I want to hear from you too
if you have a question for your business
or thought on this video let me know I
really loved seeing those come in I
really do always appreciate them and it
makes my day when they come in so thank
you guys and I'll see you on the next
episode